As we come out of this,
our expectation is that
there's going to be
good real estate out there,
unfortunately, because some restaurants
aren't going to survive this.
And the restaurants
that we're able to weather the storm
are going to be
in a good position to grow.
Chuck Imerson,
thank you for joining me.
Asian Box, I love it.
Thank you.
Oh, we love our raving fans.
That's for sure.
Chuck, thank you, first of all,
for all the amazing work
that you're doing with Asian Box.
I've had a lot of people
on this show so far.
You're probably my favorite one,
I have to say, because you brought
so much happiness to me
in my time in Palo Alto.
And that when I return to Palo Alto,
I'll continue having that great time.
But you bring such happiness
to so many different people
across the chains of Asian box.
That it's a really
an honor to meet you.
Because I think Asian Box
is a different type of restaurant
than a lot of others.
And I'll let you expand on that.
But, Chuck, before we get into that,
talk to me a little bit about yourself.
And how do you get to become
the chief executive officer
of a restaurant chain?
Well, you know,
I've been in the business
since I got out of school.
And I spent a lot of time
with Marie Callender's restaurant,
which is a well-known chain.
And then I moved over to start ups.
I actually did LYFE Kitchen,
which was also in Palo Alto.
And that meeting
with the founders of Asian Box,
and we had a good connection.
And in 2014, I came over
and joined the team
to head of operations,
and you know, with their work.
And then over time,
the founder moved on.
And I have an opportunity to move up.
And I got to take over
just before covid entered our lives.
So, it's been an exciting
and challenging time for sure.
Right.
I actually bumped into you, I remember,
in one of the Palo Alto restaurants.
And I remember sitting there
and somehow, I came to realize
that the CEO of Asian Box
is going to come.
And I just thought to myself,
"Oh, my God".
You know, I've met a bunch of CEOs
from the tech scene,
but they're not nearly as exciting
as the CEO of Asian Box,
where I eat almost every single day.
So, it was a very funny coincidence.
Chuck, give me a little bit
of insight into what Asian box is.
And why is that a bit
of a different restaurant
than the average restaurant
we would see on the street?
Well, you know,
we are Vietnamese street food.
A couple of things
I think may make us different
is that we're 100% gluten free.
You know, just naturally,
about with the ingredients we use.
So, anybody who's looking for that
can feel comfortable and safe.
Vietnamese food is your everyday food.
And with our ingredients,
we have top quality ingredients,
which I think separates us
from some of the competition.
And the food travels well.
We have good portions.
We were founded on "build your own",
which people really enjoy being
having that flexibility
of being able to you know,
create their flavor profile
that they want,
the box that they want.
In addition, now we've added
about a dozen signature boxes as well,
so, to make it easier for people
that just want to come in and
pick something with the chef together.
Right.
So, when you walk in,
you get the workout,
you get those types of things.
But you can also create your own box.
And I have to say
that one of the things
that really impressed me
when I got introduced to Asian Box,
I believe it was 2013, early 2014,
I was just running
a high school startup.
And I remember
we would always walk
to Town & Country to eat at Asian Box.
And I remember that, you know,
that everything just seemed so natural.
All the way from the plate
to the utensils.
The actual food seemed so fresh.
How do you get that?
How do you bring that feeling
to the customer?
Well, you know,
you give a lot of credit to
you know, the founders
that put it together.
Gracie Nguyen who is the chef,
it's her family recipes.
Chad and Frank
or the other two founders,
really put together everything
from the compostable container
to the sourcing,
working locally where possible
and you know, again,
the freshest quality ingredients.
And the good news is, you know,
that particular location,
that's our flagship store
that I know you've been a regular
for quite some time.
And we feed Stanford,
we feed the hospital,
we feed the high school.
And we've been very fortunate.
We have a big following there
in addition to the catering,
which, again, with our food,
the way it holds, the way it travels,
we built up, well, prior to covid,
built a strong catering business as well.
So, I think all of that
kind of comes together.
You know, the biggest thing is,
is the team, you know.
The manager that we've had,
the mangers we've had.
The one now who's been in charge
of that store,
Wendy, for several years,
it's all about she's the leader.
She sets the pace, training the staff,
developing the staff.
And all of them are, you know,
live around the community.
They all are passionate about the food,
what we're trying to do
as far as the lifestyle
and just taking care
of customers, you know,
with the smile.
Right.
You're giving a lot of
autonomy and credibility
to the restaurant manager,
Wendy, from Town & Country.
So, first of all, thank you, Wendy.
But Chuck, you're the CEO of the chain.
What is your responsibility then
as the CEO once you have
a really amazing people
running the local businesses?
Well, you know, I think,
again, it starts with the people
I mean, I've been fortunate,
we have eight stores now.
And we have eight
great managers that care.
That if I was going
to start another company,
I would happily bring
any of them over.
And to me, that's kind of
the barometer that I want to use
that these people all,
to your point, they have autonomy,
they feel a sense of ownership,
they go that extra mile.
All of our cashiers are empowered
to take care of any issue.
It's not know, you know,
they all have a level of ownership.
Or if there's a problem,
we're going to take care of it.
And it's not going to be
through a process,
it's just going to be right now.
And, you know, getting those teams,
building them
and then helping them build
their branches
and keeping them focused
on what's important. Right now,
obviously, we can't stress safety enough
with everything going on in the world.
So, we spent a lot of time talking about
that and what does that mean
and what's the perception of the consumer,
and being very ahead of
what the guest expects.
That makes a lot of sense.
And how do you think more critically
about what the guest expects?
Because as the CEO,
I'm imagining that
you're setting the tone
for the expectation
across all the chains.
Right?
Aligning the vision,
aligning the strategy that at the end,
the great people
that are working there,
they should aspire to.
So, how do you adjust to that role?
And what are some
of the thinking process
that goes on behind that?
Well, you know, it's kind of two part
when it's the business
of where are we going,
you know, long term.
Whether that's the marketing,
whether that's new menu items,
whether that's different promotions
or whatever we're offering.
But I think what's more important is
keeping it very simple for the managers.
It's you know, the restaurant business
is really a lot of common sense
and hospitality.
And if everybody understands
that we're here
to make the guest happy,
then that's our barometer
to making our decisions.
Then it simplifies it.
And the guests want the food
to come out fast, at a high quality,
obviously fresh, and made properly.
So, our procedures need to be
in place and validated.
We use where a third party service
that comes in
and acts as the health department,
in addition to the health department
and grades all the restaurants.
And we have a culinary person
who goes around
and works with the culinary teams
and teaching them new techniques
or just keeping them on track.
We do obviously,
all the safety procedures
you would expect any restaurant to do,
temperature checks
and all those throughout the day.
But the biggest thing is,
is the employees caring, you know.
And if they care,
they're going to take care of it.
And if they look at it as, okay,
I want the experience,
I'm going to deliver the experience
I want to have.
And we talk about that,
pre-shift meetings as far as
you know, we want to go fast,
but we don't want to rush.
So, the boxes need
to come out perfect every time.
And being that it's customizable,
there's a lot of different
variations of modifiers,
in addition to the fact
that there's a lot of sensitivity.
Some people are certainly,
obviously gluten free,
we don't to worry about
because we're 100% gluten free.
But we have peanuts
and other allergens that are there.
And educating our team
to be able to give the guests
what they want,
consistently, is a big deal.
And consistency
is the biggest factor, I think.
When I teach managers
and teach the employees
and from my leadership,
consistency is that number one word.
Because people can trust that.
If you're consistent,
we have a lot of regulars like yourself.
I know we have a gentleman
at Palo Alto that comes in,
I think five days a week
and get the workout.
And obviously, he wants that workout
and he wants it that way.
Right.
And we have other examples of that.
And, you know, we're very transparent.
I get a lot of feedback from the guests
and I answer as many as I can.
And they care too, you know.
They understand that being gluten free
and being a fast casual,
especially right now,
they're very supportive.
That makes a lot of sense.
So, give me a little bit of context
as to how many restaurants are there.
What is sort of the circulation
of obviously just the parameters
that you can share?
Yeah, you know,
we opened the first store in early 2012,
and then we opened two more
in the following couple of years,
late 2012, actually, 2013.
I came on in 2014.
You know, we went through
a period where we didn't grow.
And then we opened
seven stores pretty quickly
in 2016 through 2018.
And we peaked at four
in Southern California
and six in Northern California at ten.
Unfortunately, when the pandemic hit,
we made the tough decision
to let two stores go
in Southern California.
And then we have another store
in downtown LA that's temporarily closed
in part because of the pandemic,
but in part the
landlord's remodeling the center.
So, it was just coincidental timing.
So, we have seven stores operating today.
One in Irvine
and six in Northern California.
And we're throughout the peninsula
from down from San Jose
up to the Marina Chestnut store,
Burlingame, Mountain view.
And so, that's kind of
where we're at today.
We are raising money right now.
We have a series-F open.
We feel like this is
the opportunity to grow right now,
even though these
are very challenging times.
We've weathered the storm to date.
And we feel like
we're going to come out stronger.
We've been forced
like a lot of our peers,
to make tough cuts,
to really look at our business
and so to speak,
trim the fat, so to speak.
Being very efficient with our labor cost,
with our food cost.
And looking at every expense
from our POS system
to everything you could imagine,
insurances.
And we feel like we've been
very efficient at the necessity.
We thought we were efficient.
We spent a lot of 2019
really kind of becoming
a more efficient company,
a more profitable company,
getting what we call
our prime costs down,
which is the term
in combination of food and labor,
a term in the restaurant industry.
And we really got that down
to where we could grow
and potentially start franchising,
but then covid hit.
So, we looked even deeper
and made some tough decisions.
So, as we come out of this,
our expectation is that
there's going to be
good real estate out there,
unfortunately, because some restaurants
are not going to survive this.
And the restaurants that
were able to weather the storm
are going to be
in a good position to grow.
That's a very interesting way
of looking at it.
Yeah. And our thought process
is that as we get into next year,
right now, where we're as
is we basically lost
our catering business.
And I know we're not alone in that.
And that's 20% of our business.
And that hopefully will come back
when people feel comfortable
going back into the offices
and getting a comfort level.
And that might not be
till 2022 realistically.
And we understand that.
But our other business, our partners
with people like DoorDash and Grab Hub
and Uber Eats has helped us survive
in addition to, you know,
we partnered with SpotOn,
which is an up and coming POS system.
And they have the ability
for online ordering and app,
and all those things.
So, we flex great into that.
And it was kind of already in process,
but we really flex hard into that
to maximize the guests being able
to order easily and comfortably,
safely, whether they want
the food delivered
or pick up with non-contact.
We have all that happening.
And so, we built the trust back.
And over time we built
our business back up
to where, really the only thing
we're missing from last year is catering.
And like I said, I expect that
to come back eventually.
So, in a way, even though
we've gone through
a very challenging situation,
we're in a good position to grow.
And our hope is to raise some capital
and sign a couple of leases next year.
I have to say that I'm really inspired
by your take on the positioning
that you're saying,
we've entered this pandemic,
we had to make some very tough decisions,
we closed two restaurants,
we've pretty much lost
the catering business
because there really is no catering
in 2020 and likely 2021.
Yet we realize that
there are opportunities
for those that are able to
climb over the hill,
even if they're wounded.
But there are going to be opportunities
to grow into a relatively emptier market,
whether it's in real estate
or whether it's in customer acquisition.
And I'm sure that
you're thinking about that.
But I have to say that,
as a young entrepreneur
and not coming
from the restaurant scene,
I really love that entrepreneurial way
of thinking of going strong and saying,
okay, what is going to happen in the year
and how can we come out stronger.
Chuck, paint me a picture.
When covid hits,
what are the first steps
that the CEO makes
in the restaurant business?
Or what did you have to do immediately
as covid hits in order to adapt
and sort of align everybody
to this new reality that nobody knows
what's going to happen?
Yeah. You know,
I think like a lot of people,
you know, I can look at our financials
in March 17th, the day after
it was truly really announced
on a national level that,
hey, we need to lock down
and start buying toilet paper.
We really, at that point,
had a look at everything.
And we made some tough decisions,
like close four stores immediately
that I knew were going to be either
high traffic like the mall location,
the downtown location.
That I knew the offices
weren't going to be there.
And so, we paused
and we kind of evaluated
what the true impact was going to be.
And we took a hit pretty immediate,
like a lot of people.
And then we started getting strategic
and thinking about, okay,
what do we need to do.
We went to our partners,
as I mentioned earlier,
the third party delivery services
that we use.
We went to our POS system and said,
"Okay, how do we make this easier
for the guest?"
And we pivoted to that pretty quickly.
And we've seen some of our competitors.
You take, like [--],
they did make shift drive-thrus
in their parking lot because
they knew they had to compete
with the burger places
that have drive thru.
So, we knew that we needed
to make it as easy as possible
for the guests, you know,
where possible to offer curbside.
And we had some inherent challenges,
but we worked through those.
And, you know, and I think just
telling the teams,
the general managers like,
"Hey, communicate with your team,
let them know what's going on,
let's help them take care of themselves."
We have to obviously cut back
a lot of hours, help them figure out
how to get themselves taken care of,
whether it was
how to get on employment
or whatever the case may be.
Because we're all in this together.
And we had
to furlough some people immediately
and have a communication with them.
Because at the end of the day,
the hope was everybody
was going to come back.
And we wanted to make sure
that they were all still there.
And so we're still fighting that.
I have three people
on furlough right now,
still in that the catering department
and the downtown LA store
that I mentioned earlier,
that's temporarily closed.
But I've talked to those three people
every other week.
And they're ready to come back
and they're anxious.
And they've all taken part time jobs
because they've had to.
But they know
that I'm committed to them.
And as soon as we can get them back,
we will.
I think that one of the hardest things
to deal with as a leader
in any situation,
and especially in this situation,
is this uncertainty in communicating
through that uncertainty.
And one of the things that I've been
hearing a lot is this effort
to over communicate
and under communicate.
Especially in the time like covid-19.
And I think that when you're mentioning
that you're maintaining this
the responsibility towards them
and maintaining that communication,
then I think that
that's exactly the inspiration
that I'm looking at
as I'm talking to a lot of others.
Chuck, before we leave,
I want to thank you
for being so generous
with your time,
both here and with Asian Box.
Very funny coincidence that a guest
that is on the show as well,
Aliza Peleg, she's also
a board member of Asian Box,
which just blew my mind.
But it makes perfect sense.
She's a very close friend
and very, very impressive.
And I really want to thank you
for sharing those insights
and that personal experience,
the CEO of a great chain
that is just growing.
And I can't wait to see
where Asian box will continue to grow.
But before we leave,
I have to ask for the most important
and difficult question,
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Good question.
I think consistent. You know,
whenever you make decisions,
you've got to be consistent.
Just like we want the food
to come out consistently,
that way people know
where they stand
and know what's coming.
I think, you know, right now
evolving and I don't know
if that's the best word,
but we're evolving each day
as to what happens in this industry
and in the world.
And we've got to be able
to change with that
and be open minded that
what you did yesterday
may not be as successful tomorrow
if you're not open to change.
And then,
I don't know, I think communication
once again is a key word.
I don't know if that describes me,
that's more like doing something.
But, you know, I'm very big on communication.
I think It's perfect description.
Yeah. And all the managers
and a lot of our employees,
all the employees have my number.
A lot of them will text
just different ideas,
and that's how we get better.
And that's important.
I appreciate you taking the time
and being a big fan of our company.
Wonderful.
Chuck, thank you very, very much.
This is great.
Stay safe and stay healthy.
And I'm looking forward
to seeing you again
around the restaurants.
Likewise. Thanks.